a story in five words
Mariah makes millions at Christmas all
right Heather this pisses me off
billboard estimates that all I want for
Christmas is you makes as much as six
six million bucks in global Revenue each
year with 1.55 million going to Mariah
and we all know as you said at the break
it's the worst song you've ever heard
she sounds like a mating call for a
tropical bird those are your words
when I was a little girl I love Mariah
she's become a little wacky wow little
girls that means you're re you're
younger you're just saying Mariah
Carey's like 60. no she's 52 52. um but
she's still making over six million
dollars a year off this once oh
Christmas song yeah but she did go on
Stephen Colbert who you are beating now
just to let you go
and she said thirsty Applause she said
oh I only make 1 16 of a penny for every
download but we're still very thankful
well I'll take her chump change any day
yeah you know um you know Sonny this
Christmas song strategy
I think that we all have to think about
all you got to do is hit one hit it big
retire on it I'm recording a song for
next year called where does Santa poop
you know that's going to go to number
one again or at least number two
yeah you're filthy go sunny I don't
understand my revolutionary face
um and say that the biggest
beneficiaries of this are the men and
this is the patriarchy all over again
first is Nick Cannon because hey she can
afford her two kids Christmas while he
pays for the other nine yeah
um and then the record label because
they get paid close to 7 million and she
gets one of the seven so they pimped her
out real well so either way it looks
like the patriarchy always wins wow you
are so left-wing in like a completely
artificial way it's amazing it's like
you're like me on the five yeah yeah
Tyrus am I the only person that hates
Mariah Carey no voice guy to love her
Nick Cannon Nick Cannon ain't a big fan
um Nick Cannon is a great person okay
and I'm happy he's got five more than I
do but he he can afford him so give Nick
some some slack but I would say I know
this though for myself for the year come
on man
I had three eleven year olds in 2011.
sometimes it just happens
okay
how about that but
um if I was getting paid a million six a
year for one time a year I would
probably still remember the words to the
song yeah that's true
I was out doing uh New Year's
back when I had to yeah Fox and she was
performing
and she forgot the words to the song
so we got and it was like
did she really forget as the new as the
new New Year guy yeah
oh no no no this isn't sitting comfy
with you and Pete here's a hot chocolate
and cheese no no I was boots on the
ground
standing around people and piss diapers
he didn't want to miss anything it's
true they would all pee on themselves
and I stood around and I was like no
the piss diapers are real I think the
lesson here is we'll see on New Year's
yeah Fox and Friends Weekend I will not
so here's what I think I think you're
wrong I think if you were getting
mailbox money at one and a half million
dollars a year you would be mailing in
everything you would be getting that
money regardless and I think you'd
forget the words no in that song all
right we got to move on you guys hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else